In this video I will tell
for the processes that make up the whole life,
as we know it.
Its most important component is metabolism.
Metabolism.
It is a process of energy absorption in various forms,
in which it is transformed into building elements,
and then forms these elements in ways that are useful to us -
useful for energy, for our structure,
thanks to which we can actually live,
to grow, to reproduce
and coexist with our environment.
Now we'll meet you
with a series of examples related to metabolism.
Metabolism in its essence represents two different processes.
Degradation of substances
to simpler ones, in which
energy is released,
is called catabolism.
Catabolism.
This is the decomposition of the substances.
Once we have degraded the substances,
we are ready to absorb them,
as this will contribute to fabrication and renewal of tissues,
which is actually anabolism.
Anabolism.
Anabolism, with emphasis on and.
An example of how to imagine it is,
imagining that someone has built something with a Lego constructor -
and we also want to build something with Lego.
Okay, we're going to Lego the constructor
and we want to dismantle it,
but not completely.
For example, we will not get to the point where we melt the plastic.
We will disassemble it in its separate parts
and then we will build it again
in what form we actually want.
And we may not even have to disassemble it
all of his Lego parts.
You may even have built elements in the first built Lego Palace,
which are useful to us.
So let's think now how it all starts.
The exciting thing here is that it all started
or starting from the stars, from the synthesis processes in the stars.
And here is a star image,
a very familiar star for us.
It is the Sun.
Maybe you do not realize the sun
is just one of perhaps a few stars,
which are an important part of and for our existence.
The sun is the most direct source of energy for us
for the greater part of the life we ​​know.
There are some types of bacteria
and organisms that can live away from sunlight
at the bottom of the ocean, due to the heat that is given there,
but the Sun remains our main source of energy.
If I claim that other stars may be sources of energy,
including dead stars that have been in existence for billions of years,
that is because I take into account the complex elements we have created
or those who are among us in the environment
such as carbon, oxygen and so on,
generally anything other than hydrogen
is constructed from synthesis processes of hydrogen
inside the stars.
So we're really made of stardust.
And here we are, we are on Earth.
Earth is all this condensed matter
four and a half million years.
Probably, some supernova holds all this powder,
who built a previous star,
to merge this way, and so radiation is formed.
So energy from the Sun also arises.
And once again, this energy comes from synthesis processes
and is what makes the simpler elements into more sophisticated,
so the Sun also builds more sophisticated elements,
but this energy,
this energy is making its way to the Earth.
And so the organisms are formed
such as plants that use solar energy,
to convert carbon dioxide into organic compounds,
food, we would say,
which will eventually reach us.
And this process, which you may be aware of,
is called photosynthesis.
And now we will discuss some more in-depth details.
Synthesis.
As the photo word suggests in photosynthesis
the main elements of light are transformed
and there is one thing I like to ask people about,
when they first encounter the term photosynthesis,
namely that we can see how grass grows
or how wheat grows,
or how a tree grows,
but where do these elements come from?
And the most common answer is e-
"Somehow comes from the ground"
there are some nutrients that keep their origin from the ground,
but it's actually a carbon fix
and we will talk a lot about it,
especially in the carbon cycle.
Generally there is carbon dioxide in the air,
so there is carbon
there is, I will just write it in the following way.
There is carbon dioxide in the air
and what photosynthesis allows plants to do,
is to convert carbon into carbon dioxide
and form compounds with it,
turning it from gaseous to solid,
in glucose molecules, then use this glucose,
to build cellulose and other forms of starch
and whatever else.
So he uses the molecules that are in the air ...
I will draw them here ...
Uses these molecules,
who are in the air,
and solar energy to fix them
and in fact to form compounds
between carbon and other substances.
As we have said, we are built mainly of carbon and hydrogen
and we have oxygen inside,
but we are able to form these elements.
And now other living organisms,
which are the simplest single-celled organisms,
such as bacteria,
and any other types of building blocks.
I remind you, you know that photosynthesis
is not just a process involving light and carbon dioxide.
It also includes water.
So water is also involved in this process.
Water also participates.
We therefore have carbon dioxide,
CO2, sunlight and water.
Thanks to these elements, nutrients are supplied to the Earth.
And from this can be build substances such as
for example plant substances,
which use solar energy
and are a building block of some foods like bread,
and there are also other animals that eat some things
like lawns, and later begin to degrade them
in their own way, accompanied by bacteria
and then these nutrients begin to be contained
in the cow, in the milk.
And what this cow does,
is to metabolize this grass.
It can break it down,
to lead different molecules in the grass to catabolism or decay
and turn them into building blocks,
which will then build the cow,
milk and everything else.
And maybe you're wondering exactly what these molecules are,
which we continue to degrade,
and then we rebuild them again.
These are carbohydrates.
Carbohydrates,
and you will also see most of the molecules,
for which I intend to speak.
Honestly, they are all part of the nutritional content on the back of the pack,
because that tells us what's inside the food.
What nutrients will exchange your body through metabolism,
when he eats that,
what's behind the pack?
Carbohydrates are either just sugars
such as glucose or fructose,
or polymers of these sugars, which are called
polysaccharides.
It may be starch,
made of many elements.
Or many other different types of simple sugars.
We could talk about lipids.
Lipids.
Therefore, fatty acids, we could also talk about cholesterol.
These are important elements,
which are also essential for
series of biochemical reactions
in the cage,
another such element is the protein.
These are
proteins made of amino acids.
Sometimes people claim that the reason why we need proteins
is because it contains amino acids.
And so we can degrade these proteins,
to get our amino acids and digest them
in the form of new proteins.
Proteins and amino acids.
And all these substances are present
in food,
the food we eat,
which we consume
and whose substances are then metabolized by metabolism.
First, the catabolism process is carried out and we break down the substances,
then we use these building blocks,
to absorb them.
And so at the end of the day these substances provide the building blocks,
which make up our bodies.
They allow us to interact with the environment
and provide us with energy,
which energy at the end of the day,
is formed due to the presence of the molecule,
called ATP.
Here you can see the depicted ATP molecule.
Adenosine triphosphate.
And the answer to why ATP is the molecule containing it
energy-rich connections is in the three phosphate groups.
It contains these three phosphate groups,
for which we have a whole video
or actually several series of videos,
but the main answer
lies in the fact that there is a lot of energy
mostly in the last phosphate group, as I suppose.
And this energy and this compound,
as the phosphate group interrupts it, so can it separate it,
to provide all kinds of life mechanisms
including the ability of the body to exchange substances through metabolism.
Here we can see ATP, which is the presence
of energy in our lives.
And this is actually an interesting molecule.
Looking at, for example, that part of it,
it really looks like part of RNA.
Looks like you're taking ...
You have ribose, adenine
phosphate group
and can actually be used to build elements like RNA
and even DNA,
beyond that it serves for the availability of energy.
It's fun to see how all these parts interact with one another,
how they can be broken down.
We observe these processes over and over again
in biological systems which
consist of degradation
and the absorption of carbohydrates, lipids,
fatty acids, cholesterol, other substances
and proteins / amino acids.
And all this process, which we already know, constantly accompanies us,
so pay attention to your day, to the things you consume,
and you will see this process over and over again.
which is actually a bit maddening,
because in the end
the energy comes from the synthesis reaction in the stars
and all the intricate elements around you
or even less complicated,
all carbon, oxygen,
and all non-hydrogen elements
have been formed in the course of synthesis reactions
in the stars that probably exist
billions of years ago,
so you can already feel a slightly stronger relationship
with the universe.